my whole thing is words really matter
and so if you think about it from a
marketing standpoint if you call it
digital contact tracking all of a sudden
people are much more open to it right
that they're hey we need this
youthfulness and that sounds great yeah
if I said to you we're going to surveil
the population and then we're going to
label who is positive and who is not all
of a sudden that sounds a lot more scary
a lot more worrisome right and so the
language you know there's a joke that I
always go back to and I've I had to go
back and figure out who it was it was
Chris Rock or who the comedian was but
there's basically they're saying
something to the effect of the greatest
marketing campaign in the world was the
use of the word insurgent so we went
into Iraq and Afghanistan we said hey
we're taking on the insurgents we're
gonna go kill the insurgents and
everyone in the United States looked
around and said well I'm not an
insurgent you're not an insurgent I
don't know any insurgents go kill them
all kill all the insurgents but instead
we had said hey we're gonna go kill
people who are pissed off that we
invaded their country or we're gonna go
kill humans people say well I don't want
to kill the humans I thought we were
just gonna kill the insurgents right
it's got a different kind of connotation
to it when you change the language and
so I think that this is another example
where digital contact tracking sounds
very scientific it sounds very kind of
health oriented it sounds like it's
something that we as a society have to
do to stop the virus right this
invisible enemy what how do we do it
we agreed to digital contact tracking
but the static you say no we're gonna
surveil the society and we're gonna
label people to hold it from yes so just
when you hear digital contact tracing
just think in your mind citizen
surveillance and I look I was even
surprised to see Snowden and the ACLU
come out and say basically hey we're
watching this carefully but maybe it
could be good I mean it can only be bad
I mean let me explain the slippery slope
if we become more comfortable and if
this normalization of mass surveillance
is made possible through this
crisis if the government's take this
crisis and see an opportunity and say
hey here's an opportunity for us to make
mass surveillance more palatable more
reasonable we can see we can speak again
you know those signs of marketing we can
make it sound slick and call it digital
contact tracing you know where does it
end and I'll tell you where it ends it
ends with something called color coding
citizen color coding so in China in who
Bay Province and elsewhere now that
they're quote-unquote coming out of
lockdown which you know in and of itself
is arguable and I think a lot of it is a
Potemkin village based on what I know
but let's just assume that
okay so China is is regardless of
whether the virus has been beaten back
or not
they are allowing people to start to
like leave their homes etc etc etc so in
order to like leave your home go to work
get on public transportation your phone
needs to display a certain color green
yellow red and if your red you can't go
anywhere so you need to be green so who
decides what is green and what is yellow
there was a video I watched which was
quite informative from a British guys
living there now and you know he's he's
he's yellow and he's sitting in a room
with this woman who's Chinese and she's
green and they're not wearing masks and
they're just like within five feet of
each other talking and you know heard
her Cutler's not going to yellow so like
I don't know how it works but it's it's
clearly probably a little more
propaganda than actual science the point
is that you are gonna be color coded
based on how the government perceives
you as a threat to the operation of
society so it's not like you know it's
it's it's not like the app is capable of
actually understanding if you're you
know in fact it or not or have a
particular issue or not some human tells
the app you know what what you're doing
like and it gives you a score so this
builds into what we I think touched on
on on the last show about how over the
last decade the Chinese government has
been building this idea of a citizens
core which is kind of like a credit
score but it also adds behavior your
friends things like that into your
basically reliability score and for them
it's more like a patriotism score
and your patriotism score dictates you
know what kind of loan you can get where
you can travel what kind of schools your
kids can get into etc so on top of that
infrastructure which is built out you
know at the municipal level it's built
out at the corporate level there's a lot
of different experiments all around
China each region has a kind of
different one there now adding this like
color coding to the mix so now they're
basically able to control your movements
in China based on like what color you
have and there's an there's a old Soviet
joke that a dress chairman Gary Kasparov
likes to say that nothing is more
permanent than a temporary measure and
you know that could not bring more true
right now it's not like the color
codings going away and even in the West
even in our countries it's not like the
Google Apple Bluetooth con digital
context Racing's going away it's not
like they're gonna in six months delete
it off your phone no they're gonna find
a new reason for it the FBI is gonna
look at and be like hey this is actually
really useful for this other thing that
we need or some other companies gonna
say hey this would be way easier for us
to understand the marketing behavior of
our customers we want to keep it that's
coming to stay every time we like add
one of these new innovations in citizens
surveillance and behavior tracking it
doesn't go away it stays that's one
thing that we have learned and you have
to think about this idea that we are on
the slippery slope to cut to color
coding and it's gonna get more
inescapable because our devices as we've
all seen in the last two decades are
shrinking I mean that the things that we
use to communicate with each other and
rely on are going from computers that
that sit on our desks and we have to
like go to two phones that go in our
pocket to wearables that we were on our
wrist to eventually a chip dude that's
gonna be either in your wrist or your
retina or whatever I'm sure that's gonna
happen in the next twenty thirty years
absolutely and you have to think about
this like evolution of your digital
identity and how it's gonna kind of go
from kind of over the skin surveillance
to under the skin surveillance which is
a concept that you've all know Harare
the historian talks about but I think
this all ends in something that I want
to call privacy shaming I think that's
what's gonna happen as we get further
down the road and you're
to see it now I'm getting shamed on
Twitter for example for basically
sounding the alarm on the digital
contact tracing thing and trying to
challenge people on Apple and Google
project people are calling me religious
Fundamentalist of privacy absolutist
whatever I'm getting shamed and I think
like down the road especially with the
young generation I think what you're
gonna see is like it's gonna be cool to
have these like wearables chips whatever
like new devices and people who are like
caring about privacy and rights and
freedoms will maybe be uncool I think
that's gonna happen in the future we're
very worried about that and it's
something I kind of keeps me up at night
and we can we can stop it by creating an
alternative narrative that privacy is
cool you know that it's actually cool to
have rights and freedoms and it is
essential to the backbone of our society
and the country we've built here in USA
it's actually cool to protect your
livelihood and the information about
yourself and that's a narrative that I
would want to do my best to help build